e
herkese merhaba ben doktor öğretim üyesi
Özlem suça Keleş
sunum şu an geliyor Aslında Sabahtan
beri çok etkileyici sunumlar izledik
Bence bu bağlamda iletişim sosyal
olaraktan birçok ders çıkarta bileceğini
düşünüyorum ama Benim sunumum bu kadar
Aslında girişimcilik inovasyon veya
geleceği Aslında iş üzerine kurulu Bir
Hayal üzerine değil size sinema
sosyolojisinden başlayan yolculuğunu
bugün paylaşacağım ve Bu bağlamda da
sanırım geçeceğim Öncelikle sinema
sosyolojisi nedir diye bahsetmem
gerekiyor Eğer sinema sosyolojisi şu
demek arkadaşlar
sinemanın toplumu nasıl Manipüle ettiği
ve sinemanın toplumu nasıl kontrol
altında tuttuğu ile ilgili Bunu ifade
ettiğim zaman çoğunlukla öğr bu şöyle
bir geri dönüş alıyorum Hocam biz
gidiyoruz film izliyoruz dizileri takip
ediyoruz onların bize gerçekten
etkilemesi yönlendirmesi Manipüle etmesi
çok mümkün mü Evet arkadaşlar tüm sinema
tarihi bize şunu gösteriyor ki aslında
sinema devletlerin toplumu kontrol etmek
için kullandığı ideolojik bir aygıt
şimdi Bu bağlamda iletişimin tarihine
baktığımız zaman Üzülmeyin endişe etmeye
iletişim tarih anlatmayacağım ama
sinemanın geldiği noktada bugün yeni
medyanın da Bu bağlamda bir kitleyi
kontrol etme gittiği Manipüle etme
gittiği kontrol altında tutmak gibi bir
işlevinin olduğunu bize işaret ediyor
fakat tekrar sinema sosyolojisi ne
döndüğümüz zaman
Aslında geleceği hayal ettiren geleceği
düşündüren gelecek ilgili endişelere
kaygılara beden bulan bir anlatısı var
işte bu noktada Biz biz ütopyalara ve
distopya Lara başvuruyoruz şimdi Ütopya
ve bu dediğimiz zaman aklımıza hep şu
geliyor belki tanımını Sizlerde
biliyorsunuzdur Hayal edemeyeceğiniz
kadar kötü bir gelecek veya hayalini hiç
bozmak istemeyeceğiniz kadar iyi bir
gelecek şimdi Ütopya ve distopi elimize
aldığımız zaman bir film türünden
bahsetmeye başlıyoruz ve bu film türü
Aslında bize bilim-kurgu-film türünü
ortaya getiriyor şimdi janra Sizinde
Fransızca teknolojiden kulağınıza aşığı
olduğunu tahmin ettiğim filmlerin
türünün Aslında bizim zevklerimiz e
hitap etmesi ve beklentilerimizi
karşılaması korkularımız a endişelerimiz
e zemin hazırlaması bunlara cevap
vermesi bizi yönlendirmesi bizim
beklentimizin bir karşılığının olması
ile ilgili Aslında prim türlerine
belirlerken biz sinema sosyolojisi
içinde hepsine bakıyoruz sa Spain
sheinofficial Elif yani sizin
beklentinizi sinemaya girdiğiniz andan
itibaren
bu karşılaması şimdi bu karşılamayı
sağlayacak olan şeyi bu beklentiyi
Sinemada ne oluşturuyor diye baktığımız
zaman Tabi ki hikayeler yönetmenin bakış
açısı film tarihinin geçmişi veya Bu
bağlamda üretilmiş olan birçok unsur
fakat şuna bakıyoruz ki seyircilerin
gerçek anlamdaki beklentilerinin
ölçümlenmesi
seyircilerin gerçek anlamda
beklentilerini bilinmesi sinemanın
tarihinin ve hatta sinema sosyolojisinde
türlerin belirlenmesinde çok önemli bir
rol oynuyor Yani sizin bu salondaki her
bireyin bir bilet satın aldığınız zaman
koltuğa oturduğunuzda buradaki seyirci
olaraktan burada neyin anlatılacağı ile
ilgili beklentinin karşılanması ve bu
beklentiyi benim burada anlatırken
bilerek size hitap etmem Yani sizi bir
hedef kitlesi konumuna koymam Aslında
sinema sosyolojisinin bugün çalıştı en
önemli konulardan bir tanesi Şimdi bilim
kurgu türü dedim bir bilim-kurgu türü
türlerin altında bizim gelecekle ilgili
demin bahsettiğim kitopya ve distopya yı
hayatımızın merkezine koyan türlerden
biri fakat biz sinema sosu üstüne hep
şunu söylüyoruz Korku Nedir yani
Gelecekten bizi korkutan unsurları nasıl
temsil ediyoruz şimdi sinema
sosyolojisinde hep şunu söyleriz
gelecekle ilgili her Kay her ne kaygınız
varsa Bugünle ilgili yani Siz bundan
yüzyıl sonraki bir dünya için nasıl bir
hayal tezahür ediyorsanız fikir düşünce
ortaya koyuyor sanız bugünün korkuları
bugünün endişeleri Bugünün düşmanları
ile ilgilidir Dolayısıyla bilimkurgu
türüne biz sinema sosyolojisinde hep
bugün kodlarını çözümlemeleri yaparak
cevap veriniz Bu ne demek Bu şu demek
aslında Soğuk savaş döneminde Amerikan
Hollywood sinemasında yapılmış olan
filmlerin birçoğunda Aslında biz Rusya
temsillerinin da çeşitli sembollerin
beden bulmuş tekinsiz Lee'nin beden
bulmuş ya da yabancılaştıran mış beden
bulmuş hallerini görürüz Bu açıdan
baktığımız zaman da bilim kurgu türü
içerisinde Üçok yollara distopya ları
gelecek kaygılarını bu gelecek kaygıları
içerisindeki beklentiyi karşılayacak
olan tüm kodlar bugün sizlerin Aslında
görsel kültür içerisinde Popüler Kültür
içerisinde günlük rutinlerimiz
içerisinde tükettiğiniz her şeye karşı
mesafenizi beklentinizi endişelerinizi
kodluyor Şimdi ben sizin yaşınızdayken
diye başlamak istemiyorum ama gerçekten
ben sizin yaşınızdayken bilim kurgu
türlerinin Aslında anlattığı tarihler
hep bugünlere referans veriyordu uçan
arabalar işte Blade Runner filmini belki
görmüşsünüzdür Bıçak Sırtı gerçekten adı
gibi Bıçak Sırtı korkunç bir distopya
içerisinde insanlığın artık dijital
Human diyebileceğimiz ya da
Android'lerin haya o Messi tekinsizlik
beden bulması özdeşleşmenin kopması
renklerin ışıkların tabelaların Dünyayı
ele geçirmesinden bahsediyorduk ve bugün
Aslında Bıçak Sırtı filminde Latin
filminde ifade ettiğimiz o gerçekliği ya
da o tasvirin yılların dayız ama onlar
gerçekleşmedi Peki bilim kurgu türünü bu
şekilde bize ifade eden anlatan bizi bu
endişeye Taşıyan kavramlar var mı diye
baktığımız zaman Aslında Andropoz en
diye bir kavram karşımıza çıkıyor yakın
zamanda üzerine çalışmaya başladık
sinema sosyolojisinde
yeryüzündeki tüm plastik tuğla beton ve
diğer insan yapımı nesneler ilk kez
gezegendeki bitki ve hayvanların
ağırlığını aşmış olacak cümlesi aslında
antropolojinin tam tanımına karşılık
geliyor Bu ne demek yani biz gelecek
Kaygımız içerisinde insanlığın bir
şekilde kendi nesline sonlandırılmasına
neymiş ediyoruz bu bu Turgut ürünün alt
başlığından biri olan bu antropojen
sinemada Aslında biz gelecek Kaygımız ın
beden bulmuş hallerini sinemadaki
karşılıklarıyla yüz geçiyoruz
Şimdi bu filmlerin birkaçına baktığımız
zaman graffiti ile karşılaşıyoruz
melankoliye karşılaşır snowpiercer filmi
ile karşılaşıyoruz Hatta dizisiyle
herhangi bir dijital platformda da
mutlaka karşılaşmazsınız Dur şimdi
snowpiercer filmine baktığımız zaman
şunu görüyoruz bir tren insanlık yok
olmuş trenin sonunda trenin en başında
iki tane ayrı yönetici birbirlerinden
haberdar olmadığını ifade eden iki
farklı kutuplaşma sınıfı toplum yapısı
sınıfı toplum yapısı içerisinde bazı
Elif kesilen hayatını idame ettirmesi
diğerlerinin ise sadece nefes alması
şimdi bu enteresan bir endişe değil mi
bugün Geldiğimiz noktada sabahki
sunumlarda da işte iklimden bahsedeceğiz
sürdürülebilirlik ten bahsedildi
tarımdan bahsedildi Tarım bu elimizdeki
yerinden bahsedildi şimdi baktığımız
zaman filmin trenin orta kısmında Uzun
soluklu bir yolculuk var ve bu yolculuk
içerisinde insanların bitki üretmesi eti
üretmesi hayatını idame ettirebilmesi
için Yani aslında bugünün endişelerinin
karşılığını bulan sembolik değil direkt
karşılığını bulan aslında içeriklerle
bir arada bir yolculuk yapıyoruz bu
açıdan değerlendirdiğimizde antropojen
sinemada bugün kaygılarını Aslında
insanlığın geleceğinde nasıl
yaşayacağını tezahür ederek üretilen
filmlerde Biz bugün korkumuzu endişe
mizi ve Aslında karşılaşmak
istemediğimiz geleceği görüyoruz Bu bize
Bilinç dışımızda soydun ifadesiyle
aslında hiçbir şey ifade etmiyor Freud
diyor ki gerçek Yüzleşme ile Ancak ve
ancak onu gördüğünüzde anlarsınız yani
siz bir olayı bir örgüyü bir durumu
karşılaştığınızda fark edince kadar O
sizin hep bilinçdışınız da sizi
tetikleyici sizi Çağırıcı Sizi orada
tutacak ve size endişe ettirecek Ha o
Tekin sizi size sürekli sunacak bir
yaklaşımda sizi beyninizi yer Bu
bağlamda snowpiercer ve Gravity filmi
bizim antropojen sinema içerisinde
gerçekten insanların gelecek kaygıları
ile ilgili beden bütünlüğünü devam
ettirebilecek mi neslini devam
ettirebilecek mi işte gıdaya
ulaşabilecek mi temiz suya ulaşabilecek
mi gibi gibi birçok soruyor Aslında
cevabını aradığımız endişem izi Kaygımız
abeden bulduğumuz filmler şimdi peki
korkuyor tetikleyen şeyine burada yani
biz yatıyoruz Bir Sabah kalkıyoruz bir
işte ilk sinema örneğini antropojen de
demeyelim bir tür olaraktan benim
kurguda dinleyelim bizim korkumuzu
tetikleyen şeyine burada Bizim korkumuz
tetikleyen şey aslında dijital ayak izi
bu veya gölgelerimiz şimdi konuyu
sinemadan aldık yeni Medya doğru
taşıyoruz araya sinema ile ilgili
türleri yerleştirdik bugün Geldiğimiz
noktada sinema üretimi geleneksel sinema
üretiminin ötesine geçerek ten
insanların korkularını günlük hayat
rutinlerin de ki kullanımlarından
filtreleyerek de ortaya çıkartıyor yani
siz bir dijital platformda bir filme
beğeni istek talep bekleme izleme
durdurarak izleme bekleterek izlemeye
tekrar izleme gibi bir Reaksiyon
gösterdiğiniz zaman sizin bundan sonra
izleyeceğiniz film ile ilgili üç yıllık
beş yıllık konjonktürde Aslında Neyi
tekrar izleyebileceğiniz ile ilgili bir
veri bir data oluşturduğumuz için
gelecekle ilgili kaygılarınız da da
ilgili ayak izleri oluşturmaya
başlıyorsunuz dahası günlük hayat bütün
yerinizde satın alma larınız beğenme
leriniz alışverişleriniz Bu beğenileri
anonim hesaplardan yapmanız ve var yani
hesaplarınızdan çeşitli biçimlerde
yapıyor olmanız hep dijital ayak
izleriniz içerisinde Aslında sizin
gelecek kaygılarımızın nasıl olabileceği
ile ilgili işaretler soruyorum şimdi bu
işaretlerin sinemaya aktarımına
baktığımız zaman dijital platformlar Tüm
bu verileri işleyerek ten Aslında Hedef
kitlenin neyi beklediğini neyden endişe
ettiğini ve korku duyduğu bu korkuyu
nasıl Manipüle edebileceği veya bu korku
nereye yönlendirebilecek ile ilgili
Analitik çalışmalar yapıyor senaryoları
Buna göre kurguluyor senaryoları görsel
efektlerin iki antropojen sinemada bu
görsel efektlerin Aslında her endişenin
her korkunun bir beden bulması sembolü
olarak bedenini bulması ki sinema
sosyolojisi ne bulunan okunabilmesi
sağlayacak biçimde anlatılır Dolayısıyla
dijital platformlar bunları çalışıyor
bugün baktığımızda dijital platformların
Yayıncılık ilkeleri içerisinde özellikle
ve özellikle yapımcılığı altını çiziyor
olmaları bu Hedef kitlenin tüm dijital
ayak izini ve gölgelerine vakıf
olabilmeleri ve tekrar Neyi izleyeceğini
biliyor olmaları yer alıyor Şimdi
gelecekle ilgili kaygılarımızı
baktığımız zaman mesai yakın zamanda
into the night diye bir dizi ile
karşılaştık Türk versiyonu Yakamoz diye
bir dizi ile karşılaştık bunlara
baktığımız zaman sinematografik öğeleri
kurgusu ritmi vesaire si beğenilir
beğenilmez Tartışmaya açık Yani biz
Aslında güneşin bir gün bizi yakacağını
Güneşe karşı gelemeyeceğim izi veya işte
gün ağırdı zaman karşılaştığımız oy
akıcılıkla baş edemeyeceğimizi ve kendi
aramızda işte sınıflı toplum yapısının
kodlarını Taşıyan farklı kademedeki
insanlarla bir araya gelip hayatta
kalmaya çalışacağımız da ilgili bir
endişe mi zor Şimdi bunu baktığımız
zaman bu dizinin üretim süreci pandemi
sürecine denk geliyor yani insanları en
çok kaygılarını tetiklendiğinde bu en
çok gerçekteki sosyal hayatlarından
Aslında uzak Kaldıkları ev içerisine bir
şeyleri daha fazla tükettikleri bunu
tüketirken daha fazla Algoritma
ürettikleri bu algoritmaların daha
üretilebilir hale geldiği ve
üretilebilirlik dolayısıyla daha fazla
işlendiği bıdı bıdı bıdı bıdı İlerleyen
bir süreçte ta ki dizilerin filmlerin
üretim biçimine kadar gidiyor
ezcümle
dijital insan ayak izi olaraktan aslında
bunları analiz ettiğimiz noktada sizin
günlük hayat rutininiz içerisinde
beğendiğiniz endişe ettiğiniz
bağladığınız engellediğiniz konuştuğunuz
heştek dediğiniz ifade ettiğiniz her şey
bunun beş yıl veya on yıl sonrasındaki
dijital insanların algoritmaları için
ayak izlerini oluşturacak Şimdi bunu
Aslında bir çok yerde size mutlaka ki
karşılaşıyorsunuz kodlarıyla Bu ne demek
diye detroit Bir kamyonun oyunu belki
aranızda bilenler vardır Bu ve sinema
sosyolojisi içerisinde hem detroit
become Human oyunun paradigmaları Nasıl
ama sonra fikirlerini hem de işleyişi
açısından
karar verme mekanizması nasıl
etkilediğine baktığımızda şununla
karşılaşıyoruz etroit bir kamyon oyunu
beş yıl sonra bir insanın başka bir
insanı sokakta öldürdüğü zaman nasıl
tepki verileceği ile ilgili
algoritmaları topluyor Yani siz sokakta
yanınıza geçen biri herhangi bir durumda
öldürüldüğü zaman yürüyecek misiniz
müdahale edeceksiniz yerden taş alıp onu
savunacak mısınız koşarak uzaklaşacak
mısınız hepsini detaylı bir şekilde
algoritmasını döküyor ve bunu ne için
yapıyor bunu sizin bireysel olaraktan
Ayşe Ahmet Mehmet olaraktan değil gerçek
anlamda beş yıl sonra üretilebileceği on
yıl sonra üretilebileceği belki
inanmazsın rüyalarında gördüğü o dijital
insanın nasıl bir karar verme
mekanizması olması gerektiği ya da bu
şansız araçların gerçekte nasıl bir
davranışa yönlendirilebilir eceee Nasıl
tepki vereceğini nasıl ölçülebileceğini
nasıl duracağı ile ilgili algoritmaları
bugün siz dijital ayak izlerinizi
sağlıyorsunuz Yani hiçbir tercih hiç bir
beğeni hiçbir banlama hiçbir engelleme
hiç bir oyun hiçbir dijital kültürünü
sadece dijital kültürünü değil sizin
bundan sonraki nesillerde jenerasyonlar
da karşılaşabileceğiniz işte filmler
için diziler için oyunlar için dijital
insanlar için Aslında bugün ufkun
ötesinde bugün işaret eden bugünden
temel lenen bugünün inşa ettiği kodlarla
geleceğin referans bulacağı bir şeyleri
inşa ediyorsunuz Ve siz bunu
oluşturuyorsunuz yoksa Bundan on yıl
önce antropojen sinemadan bahsetmiyor
duk insanların kaygılarını bu kadar bu
kodlarla ifade etmiyorduk Çünkü
insanların plastikten daha fazla bir
nüfusu vardı ama bu Geldiğimiz noktada
ilk defa insanların nüfusunu ürettiği
Aslında kontrol ettiğine inandığı
Aslında hüküm sürdüğüne inandığı ve
doğayı kontrol edebileceği ne inandığı
gücünün üstünde
ürünlerle karşılaşıyoruz işte gerçekle
Gelecekle kaydınızı Biz bugün inşa
ediyoruz Umarım sizler için verimli bir
konuşma olmuştur Çok teşekkür ede